i saw this movie in theaters and again
like like what nina said like my hair
was blown back my head exploded i was
like oh my god perfect movie i got out
of that movie and one of the guys i saw
it with was like i didn't like it it
wasn't funny and i was like and you
killed him no yeah and then now he's
dead
so today we are going to talk about
movies that completely changed
halfway through you know when you start
watching a movie
and you think i know what this movie's
all about and then by the time you get
to the end you go what did i just watch
and sometimes that works out really
really well because you're like well
that wasn't what i expected at all and
other times you want to flush your tv
down the toilet uh we're going to talk
about those movies so nina what's your
pick for a movie that completely changed
halfway through
thanks for asking ryan so
i always say that uh so i'm going to
pick an example of one that i think did
it perfectly and i don't think
i don't think that this is gonna be a
particularly spicy take i think
if you've seen this movie
and we should probably and once i start
talking about it we'll have to put a
spoiler warning up if you've seen this
movie you know what i'm talking about um
so
in i think it was mid-2019 maybe closer
to the fall by the time this was
released where i lived but it was in you
know towards the end of 2019 so i go to
see a movie by myself and i was like i
don't really know much about this movie
but i've heard great things i want to
check it out and uh i don't know two-ish
hours later i left parasite
so stunned oh
sure i was like i think i walked in a
circle for 20 minutes just being like oh
my god what did i watch what did i watch
what did i watch oh my god oh my god
great one
that's i love yeah again this is not a
spicy take parasite is a is a great film
it's i've watched it so many times since
and i keep finding new things in it and
i just think it's it's
flawless i think it's perfect but i've
read a lot of uh stuff about how bong
joon ho a genius
structured the movie he didn't do a
three-act structure so the
uh
spoilers um the part where the
housekeeper shows up at the house is the
exact like when the family has overtaken
the rich family's house and they're all
hanging out in there and drinking
the housekeeper ringing the doorbell is
the exact midway point of the script
itself
which i didn't know until like he
started talking about it because in the
beginning it's it reminds me of a heist
movie it's like this caper where this
family you know they're like oh we can
trick this very gullible wealthy family
we can get ourselves jobs we can you
know infiltrate their lives and it's
kind of you know it's perversely funny
and it's it has some lift to it you
think it's going in such a direction
where their lies will be exposed and
they'll have to cover it up and this
that the other thing you're like okay i
know where this is going yeah you have
you think you have a sense of like
what's going on and the whole like
jessica from chicago like that stuff is
like kind of funny
in a dark way and then all of a sudden
you're like is this a horror movie and
it is basically i mean it's a very
intense thriller from that point on and
i swear to god when i was in in the
theater and she's the woman is trying to
open that underground passage like
sideways i was like oh my god is she a
demon what's gonna happen i didn't know
what to expect
and i and then i would tell people to go
see it and they'd be like what's it
about and i'd be like i'm not telling
you anything you need to go into this
movie blind you you should not know
anything so yeah i mean it won best
picture which like made me overjoyed it
was so well deserved i don't think i
need to be like
selling anyone on the parasite is a good
movie but yeah it was it's such an
unexpected turn because bong joon-ho is
so so so good at what he does he's such
a good storyteller he's such a great
writer and director and
and he doesn't do anything by accident
so every single part of the first part
of that movie is so carefully
you know preparing you for that for that
turn which is magnificent yeah set up
and pay off yeah perfect even just like
from like someone saying yeah set up and
pay off like the little boy says like
that one of the family members smells
bad or something and then like later
that like that all comes full circle i
mean it's just
yeah it i've never been so like had my
like hair blown back by a movie in
theaters in my life because i was just
like
wow i have no idea what i just watched
and i loved every second of it like
first viewing such a great pick
the first viewing of that i want to like
erase it i want to eternal sunshine it
for my brain so i can watch it again
that's awesome i love that movie yeah
that's such a good pick that i have i
have a couple on here that feel in that
same vein but i'll i'll save him for a
bit tom what's your pick for a movie
that changed halfway through that you'd
like to talk about
i was thinking about a couple of them
one of my favorites is uh
i really like martin mcdonough movies uh
oh i love martin mcdonough yeah yeah i'm
not making any i'm i'm ignorant i don't
know i don't even know that name i'm
sorry he's written um he wrote in bruges
with colin farrell and yeah gleason and
three billboards outside of epic
missouri yeah okay all right and also a
a play that takes place in my hometown
it's called uh called the be handing in
spokane that he wrote five four
sam rockwell and christopher walken and
i think anthony mackie
yeah terrific really great he's actually
primarily a primarily a playwright a
really good playwright
yeah he's he's wonderful and uh
and weird and kind of dark and
uh
and in between in bruges and uh and
three billboards he had a movie that
came out that i don't
i i i don't know people didn't seem to
pay as much attention to it and uh
in their defense like it's
the movie
is firmly up its own but it's it's uh
it's very like
so martin mcdonough's the guy that wrote
it the main character is a writer named
marty
who
is struggling with the fact that his
movies are too
late
they're not doing the things that he
wants them to do it's really
interesting yeah no like there's there's
some
there there's some pretension there but
uh
terrific really weird movie and the
whole thing kind of feels like it's
gonna turn into a
quentin tarantino bloodbath at the end
but at the point where it probably
should instead of that uh the main
characters
just kind of drive into the desert and
camp out for about half an hour and just
talk it's just i'm talking about huh
what should story structure be
what should happen next i don't think
you've told us oh okay yeah it's called
seven psychopaths it's
that sounds familiar okay it's got a
really good isn't same rock was on that
as well right it's got a really good
cast sam rockwell i i liked him better
than that then i liked him in three
billboards he's i agree yeah really
weird he's a great character for him
uh
another regular colin farrell yeah yep
totally yeah great movie really fun
all right i'll have to check that out
okay those are great picks wow so so far
we're picking good movies we're movies
that aren't good people
we're smart good people so that's why
we're saying these let's talk about some
that that maybe don't work i have one
right off the bat from this from this
here list on
looper.com uh it's probably one it's if
you were to ask me you know just point
blank like pick a movie that changes
halfway through i'd say this first
without thinking and it's hancock have
you oh have you seen hancock oh yeah
not for a long time like i think when it
came out
i remember when it came out and it
didn't do very well it got bad reviews i
was like oh that's weird and then
because like the trailers look pretty
good and then i saw it like when i was
like hanging out with a friend it was
like on vod or whatever so we rented it
i was like how bad could it be and i was
like oh real bad it's not good it starts
off as a kind of a parody of superheroes
where he's like a crappy superhero it's
like what if superman had a drinking
problem there you go great premise to a
movie right it's a pretty good premise
like what if he was just a bum sketch
yeah or whatever right isn't it also
like
whatever isn't it also kind of like the
pre like avengers and the boys thing of
like what if like what about the damage
superheroes dude to cities absolutely
because those are both things that
really address that like you know in
more detail now but that wasn't a thing
for a long time so much that works in
this in the first half of this movie
where you know hancock's got these
problems he stinks like he's making all
these mistakes left and right jason
bateman comes along and he's like i'm
going to rehabilitate your image so
you've got you talking about marketing
you're talking about branding you're
talking about consumerism
through the superhero lens like um and
stardom through the superhero lens all
this great stuff and then halfway
through the movie you find out that
jason bateman's wife
is also a secret superhero and they're
both immortal and they've both been
alive for thousands of years and you're
like
what
it's shyamalan it's pretty hard
what happened to this movie because now
it's something else and it's awful
so
that's why does surely sharon love
playing immortal characters because she
doesn't age
i mean she yeah she looks like that's
okay
i'll accept that answer you know yeah
that wasn't that wasn't me trying to
knock charlie's there because she could
knock the crap out of me and i love her
so
all of us another good one on here is
from dusk till dawn have you guys seen
that one such a weird turn
early early in george clooney's movie
career
i remember watching this movie it was
like on stars or something when i was in
high school it was on stars a lot i feel
like i watched the first if i was
watching it and the first half is this
awesome like crime caper like uh george
clooney and quentin tarantino take this
family hostage they're trying to get out
of town or whatever and then halfway
through vampires show up and it's a
vampire monster movie and it's insane
and again it's like
i would even say that both of those
movies are pretty okay but stuck
together
you're kind of like
do i want this i would rather see one of
these movies have a beginning middle and
end was it it feels like the precursor
to like the the death proof and what was
the other like when it was the two
movies that tarantino and robert
house
thank you yeah
thank you i was like really blanking on
those but yeah it's like those are two
separate things and they're stuck
together but you know they're supposed
to be i'm not saying they're perfect but
like
i they know what they are yeah yeah i
i liked from dusk till dawn i like i i
kind of like
being really good so i was i think i was
more just kind of like annoyed that i
didn't get to see the resolution of the
movie i started
but if i'm sure if i revisit it today
i'd probably share your opinion because
i don't remember
it being bad i was mostly just baffled
by
there's this one there's one part
there's one part i don't think we can
show this but i'll just describe we'll
probably like censor it but there's one
part where like a vampire's playing
electric guitar with a dead body that's
naked or something i remember some
insane thing so i just remembered that
being a very heavy contrast with what
had come before
i don't think robert rodriguez is like
the subtlest director in the world
you mean the guy who who did spy kids is
not so
i think i think i think maybe he he
loves himself some camp some yeah
healthy good old-fashioned camp so i
would
i mean i'm gonna side with i'm a little
more here in that like i think that
movie knows what it knows that it's
insane and like that's kind of the
pleasure of it i need to revisit it but
i think i think it does yeah it was it's
a really good choice because the first
time you watch it you're like what but i
think it's very
i think it's more self-aware that i'm
probably remembering because i think
rodriguez is very aware of what he's
doing a lot of time fantastic uh
practical effects in that movie tom
cevini one of like the the kind of
godfathers of practical effects uh is in
it as as one of the patrons at the
vampire bar
and he's got he's uh he's the one that's
got the uh speaking of things that we
would have to censor uh he's got the
belt buckle gun that flips open
then also shows up in
desperado oh
right i forgot about that good night i
have two more pics for this one
uh not from this article unfortunately
um
but one i just i mentioned in a recent
video is a movie adaptation
yeah the first half of the movie is this
mia it's very similar to what you
discussed what you described in seven
psychopaths where it's a movie about a
writer
writ you know written by charlie kaufman
starring nicholas cage as charlie
kaufman trying to write the movie that
you are watching and the whole first
half just goes in circles nothing
happens like any event that happens is
not actually contributing to the story
moving forward it's just stuff happening
and then halfway through his dumb twin
brother donald writes the rest of the
movie like a typical hollywood
box checking movie that charlie
specifically said he didn't want it to
become and it does perfectly and it's
great so that's one i love that movie
the other one
is a another favorite of mine
is a movie called hot fuzz
and the reason i bring it up oh great
choice
right choice
i saw this movie in theaters i saw this
movie in theaters and again like like
what nina said like my hair was blown
back my head exploded i was like oh my
god perfect movie perfection i got out
of that movie and one of the guys i saw
it with was like i didn't like it it
wasn't funny and i was like and you
killed him no yeah and then now he's
dead
but that's because the whole first half
of the movie
is the setup
and the whole second half or at least
whatever that cut is when it turns into
an action movie is the payoff like
that's
set up our punch line even you know it's
just like every it's it's one joke but
the the first half of the joke is
you know an hour long and this the punch
line is a half an hour it's what if we
make a joke about action movies and then
that's the punchline at the end it's
just like the turn is perfect
everything is just it's so funny it's so
good and it is it's like two you're
watching two different movies because
one is a
silly goofy
parody of of cop
dramas that is like is very light on
action
but making jokes about it and then the
second part is all the action that you
wanted from the first part and as funny
as possible in a small town in england
it's one of the
best movies ever made it's one of the
best movies ever made there i said it
another really really spicy take that
hot fuzz is a good movie actually like
whoa deal with that
no it's funny you bring up hot fuzz
because like as we were talking i
recently watched this is super recent so
uh i'll try i'll try to keep it
relatively spoiler free but i watched
last night in soho recently which i
mostly enjoyed i think it's really
ambitious and i love that about it i
don't think it quite sticks the landing
but that's its own thing but it really
likes which you mentioned because it's
also an edgar wright movie yes sorry
again that's where that's the where the
train of my brain was going yeah
yeah yes and so like yeah i just watched
that i love edgar wright i'm a huge
i mean another super hot take wow just
crushing it today yeah and uh so i was
really excited to see last name soho
because i love him and i love anna
taylor joy and all that stuff but
you know the first half is this like
very glamorous like you know period
piece set in the 1960s in london and
it's glitzy and then all of a sudden it
kind of descends into just absolute
horror um and it doesn't really prepare
you for that and like it
like i said it kind of works up until
i i deeply respect that wright just
really went went for it in this movie
and i'm gonna leave it it'll leave you
guys to watch it because i think i'm the
only one here who has but like you know
you gotta check it out he's stumbling
he's really he is typically like half
house is a perfect example of that right
where he like he takes a huge leap and
it so works
it couldn't work better and like
so i mean that's what that's what's so
great about him is he he's one of the
only directors willing to be like let's
try this really crazy turn in this movie
and see if we can pull it off
yeah
yeah it works great it works great yeah
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe
[Music]